Bernie Sanders and Chuck Schumer have
introduced a plan to restrict corporate
stock buybacks this would be an
unprecedented step in the government
basically telling business what they
could do with their money but is this
just political rhetoric or is there
something to this so the whole plan
centers around stock buybacks and that's
essentially when companies take the
money they have saved up and use it to
buy back shares in the stock market
the result is earnings per share the
profit a company makes for every share
goes up and that often drives up the
stock price the Democrats want companies
to be required to do something for their
employees give them raises improve their
pensions things like that before they
give money back to shareholders but hold
on a moment how did we get here
the political issue which you're gonna
hear about a ton over the next two years
is wages for the middle class have just
stagnated for the last 20 years the
average American family makes around
$60,000 a year and that's roughly the
same as it was 20 years ago
politicians realized there's a lot of
anger about that it's one of the reasons
Donald Trump was elected and the
Democrats are gonna try to use it to get
back into power when Donald Trump took
office soon after they had this big tax
cut and that the major impact of that
was corporate profits went up but also
the economy did really well and that
drove down the unemployment rate which
helped workers one criticism of the
Trump tax plan is that the companies
used a lot of that money and just bought
back stock and so they did not give
workers raises necessarily and what they
did do was buy back shares drive up the
stock price and as everyone knows the
people who owned stock the biggest
owners of stock are are rich people and
so this was a scene as a give back to
the rich while the workers didn't get
much the counter-argument is the money
that goes to the buybacks goes to
investors and they reinvest it and that
boosts the economy another underlying
issue is over the past couple of decades
a big trend has emerged in corporate
America so companies make revenue and
that revenue is split between profits
and wages for employees and the portion
going to profits has gone up a lot the
share taken by employees has gone down
so the idea behind the Democrats plan is
companies are going
have to give employees something a raise
better benefits etc before they can
benefit their shareholders now that goes
against tradition and you know all the
precedents before which is companies
basically can control the cash they have
one of the problems with a plan like
this is if I'm a company I'm sitting on
ten billion dollars in cash well if
there are restrictions on what I'm gonna
do in terms of a buyback I'm just not
gonna buy back the stock I'm just gonna
leave the money sitting in my bank
account and that doesn't benefit anybody
the other problem is companies are not
gonna give workers raises unless they
have to unless the wages for all other
industries around them are going up I
think the Democrats are trying to take a
stand they're trying to make this an
issue in the campaign
there are more conventional ways to
accomplish similar goals so you can do
tax cuts for working class people you
can raise the minimum wage Republican
Senator Marco Rubio has a plan out now
where they would tax essentially the
corporate buybacks it would work like a
dividend payment where the shareholders
would get a bill when the company bought
back stock so you can do tax cuts for
working class people you can raise the
minimum wage other Republicans will talk
about well we need to reduce regulation
increase investment and get the economy
growing and that's what makes workers
earn more money the Democrats just
control the House of Representatives so
this bill isn't going anywhere but the
rhetoric and the discussion around
middle-class wages and working-class
wages is going to be with us for a long
time